son las 8 y 29 de la noche en Bogotá
quito y Lima continuamos en directo
América edición nocturna Les agradecemos
su sintonía vamos con los titulares de
esta jornada
como una decisión histórica calificó el
presidente de Ucrania abuelo
dimircelenski la orden de arresto contra
el presidente ruso Vladimir Putin
emitida por la Corte Penal Internacional
por su presunta responsabilidad en la
deportación ilegal a Rusia de niños
ucranianos el kremlin aseguró que se
trata de una medida jurídicamente nula
y Turquía dio el visto bueno el
presidente reyeta y pidió al parlamento
de su país que ratifique la adhesión de
Finlandia a la otan la decisión pone fin
a meses de incertidumbre y
conversaciones El mandatario Turco
resaltó que las negociaciones con Suecia
para la entrada en la alianza se
mantiene
en Francia continuaron por segundo día
consecutivo las multitudinarias
protestas y los posteriores disturbios
por el anuncio del gobierno galo de
aprobar la controversia del reforma a
las pensiones sin el debate en la
asamblea nacional esto el tiempo que la
oposición oficializó dos mociones de
censura que se prevé podrían ser votadas
el lunes
[Música]
[Aplausos]
damos inicio con las reacciones a la
orden de arresto emitida por la Corte
Penal Internacional contra el presidente
ruso Vladimir Putin por su supuesta
responsabilidad en la deportación de
menores ucranianos a zonas controladas
por Rusia lo que constituye un crimen de
guerra Bueno dime silensky señaló que se
trata de una medida histórica mientras
que desde el kremlin aseguraron que sus
efectos son jurídicamente nulos Alba
Santana nos amplía
es oficial la Corte Penal Internacional
emitió una orden de arresto contra el
presidente de Rusia Vladimir Putin por
cometer supuestos crímenes de guerra
tras la invasión de Ucrania en febrero
de 2022
los jueces han revisado la información y
las pruebas presentadas por el fiscal y
han determinado que existen acusaciones
creíbles contra estas personas por
presuntos crímenes
el organismo emitió la orden contra
Putin y María el boba belova comisaría
para los derechos de la infancia como
sospechosos a por deportación de niños y
traslado forzoso de ucranianos Pero cómo
de probable es que se lleven a cabo
estas detenciones la Corte Penal
Internacional es un organismo que solo
puede ejercer jurisdicción sobre los
países afirmantes del acuerdo y Rusia no
lo es por eso no tiene poder para
extraditar a los sospechosos algo por lo
que el kremlin señaló esta orden de
detención o como nula
Ahora sí Rusia al igual que varios
estados no reconoce la jurisdicción de
este tribunal y en consecuencia
cualquier decisión de este tipo es nula
para la federación rusa desde el punto
de vista del derecho
no obstante esta decisión sí tiene un
fuerte peso simbólico está pensada para
dañar la imagen de Putin a nivel
internacional y le dificultará viajar
especialmente a los países que están
inscritos a la cpi como Francia o Reino
Unido ya que los miembros están
obligados a restar a cualquier persona
acusada por el tribunal
es una decisión histórica a partir de la
cual comenzará la responsabilidad
histórica el jefe de estado terrorista y
otros funcionarios rusos se han
convertido oficialmente en sospechosos
de crímenes de guerra
mientras Rusia ha querido restar
importancia a la decisión Ucrania y los
países miembros de las dpi sostienen que
abre una vía para perseguir
responsabilidades pero lo cierto Es que
es muy poco probable que Putin tenga que
sentarse en el banquillo de los acusados
del tribunal
el presidente de Turquía
Perdona dio luz verde al ingreso de
Finlandia a la otan dejando de momento
al otro aspirante que Suecia en la
espera en su reunión con su homólogo
finlandés erdogan anunció que iniciara
pronto el proceso de ratificación las
diferencias con Suecia a las que a la
que Turquía acusa de albergar
aterroristas Siguen sin limarse como
veremos en el siguiente informe de
humanizada
Finlandia tiene luz verde para ingresar
a la otan tal como se esperaba Turquía
dio el visto bueno a uno solo de los
nuevos candidatos y dejó a Suecia fuera
de la ecuación
no es posible para nosotros acercarnos
positivamente a Suecia en las actuales
condiciones no tenemos los mismos
problemas con Finlandia hemos decidido
iniciar el proceso de ratificación en
nuestro parlamento la decisión fue
anunciada durante una recepción con el
presidente finlandés luego de meses
objetando el ingreso de los nórdicos
bajo la acusación de que albergaban
grupos terroristas en alusión de
militantes del proscrito partido de los
trabajadores del kurdistán pkk celebran
con cautela Finlandia y la otan
tengo la sensación de que la pertenencia
la otan no está completa Sin Suecia
Tenemos tantos intereses en común al ser
vecinos y tener el área del mar Báltico
en nuestras costas
lo más importante es que tanto Finlandia
como Suecia se conviertan en miembros
plenos rápidamente No si se unen
exactamente al mismo tiempo
Mientras tanto Suecia no pierde las
esperanzas se trata de cuando Suecia se
convertirá en miembro no de Sí en
términos de nuestra seguridad nuestra
posición es mejor ahora que cuando
solicitamos el ingreso en la otan la
admisión de Finlandia no es un triunfo
completo ni siquiera para helsinki de
acuerdo con este analista
la defensa de Finlandia en términos
prácticos realmente necesita
coordinación con Suecia geográficamente
es muy significativa en los planes de
defensa de Finlandia y en los de la otan
en la Europa del Norte
ambos países solicitaron su ingreso a la
alianza atlántica a raíz del inicio de
la invasión rusa en Ucrania pero este
depende del favor unánime de los 30
países miembros vamos a Francia donde
dos grupos de la oposición oficializaron
mociones de censura contra el gobierno
de la primera ministra Elizabeth luego
de que El Ejecutivo anunciara que
aprobará la reforma a las pensiones sin
la discusión en la asamblea nacional
este viernes por segundo día continuaron
las protestas contra la medida que está
consagrada en el artículo 49:3 de la
constitución en varias zonas del país
las movilizaciones terminaron en choques
con la policía los detalles a
continuación
con el 49 3 el artículo utilizado para
impulsar la polémica reforma de las
pensiones este jueves y en el derecho de
replicar el parlamento francés en forma
de votos de censura dos de ellos se han
presentado este viernes y se espera que
se voten el lunes los que penden de un
hilo son la primera ministra Elizabeth y
su gabinete bona utilizado el 493 para
evitar una votación parlamentaria un cbc
desde que asumió el cargo del año pasado
lo diferente esta vez Es que hay una
nueva posibilidad de que los partidos de
la oposición se unan detrás de una
alianza no partidista de diputados
conocida como el grupo
el grupo libertad independientes
territorios de ultramar
presentará una moción de censura con 91
firmantes de cinco grupos de la
oposición Lamento que mis colegas de lr
no sean firmantes Pero espero que muchos
voten a favor
esta moción ha sido firmada por
independientes y miembros de la
coalición de izquierdas nubes el poder
de hacer o deshacer esta Alianza está en
manos de los diputados del partido
conservador los republicanos sus líderes
han descartado apoyarla pero algunos
legisladores han dicho que romperían
filas la ultraderechista agrupación
nacional presentó una segunda moción que
previsiblemente obtendrá menos respaldo
Aunque una diputada dijo que su partido
votaría a favor de todas las nociones de
censura presentadas para ser aprobada
una moción de censurar requiere un
mínimo de 287 votos más de la mitad de
la asamblea nacional talazania obligaría
al gobierno a dimitir otra opción para
macron sería despedir a la primera
ministra Elizabeth que ha estado al
frente del debate sobre las pensiones
en España acabó la huelga de médicos de
familia y pediatras en Madrid que
llevaba activadas de noviembre de 2022
tras 4 meses de continuas marchas
manifestaciones y 15 reuniones con la
consejería de salud los sanitarios y el
gobierno madrileño firmaron un acuerdo
que satisface algunas de las demandas de
Los profesionales de la salud más
detalles en el informe de Marina
Colorado corresponsal de France 24 en la
capital española
primer día de cierta normalidad en los
centros de salud de Madrid como este que
tengo a mis espaldas hoy a las 8 de la
mañana se desconvocaba la huelga de
médicos de atención primaria y pediatras
que se mantuvo durante 115 días el
acuerdo firmado entre los responsables
de sanidad de la comunidad de Madrid y
el comité de huelga de Los profesionales
de la salud establece entre otras
medidas un tope al máximo de pacientes
diarios 34 paramédicos y 24 para
pediatras que tendrán Entre 10 y 15
minutos para cada uno de sus pacientes
una rebaja significativa ya que
actualmente las agendas a veces
superaban los 60 pacientes al día por
cada médico además habrá un incremento
salarial de 450 euros mensuales para
todos y bonos de hasta 500 euros
adicionales al mes para quienes cubran
el turno de tarde precisamente los bajos
salarios era una de las principales
quejas entre los sanitarios en Madrid
región de la que el 70% de los médicos
residentes formándose para en atención
primaria querían marcharse por las malas
condiciones laborales Y es que Madrid no
dedica ni el 11% de su presupuesto en
sanidad a la atención primaria cuando la
media nacional está en un 15% una cifra
Por cierto muy por debajo de lo
recomendado por la Organización Mundial
de la Salud que está en un
25%. para los médicos que aseguran estar
moderadamente contentos con este acuerdo
este es solo el primer paso para frenar
así la hemorragia de la sanidad pública
madrileña la Organización Mundial de la
Salud Indicó que prevé rebajar la alerta
por el 19 este año para que la amenaza
sea considerada equiparable a la que
representa la gripa estacional Michael
Ryan jefe de los programas de urgencia
de la OMS explicó que el virus es un
riesgo para la salud pero ya no perturba
ni la sociedad ni los sistemas
hospitalarios el anuncio llega luego de
que el pasado fin de semana se
cumplieran tres años desde que la
organización declaró por primera vez la
situación como una pandemia
yo creo que estamos llegando a ese punto
en el que podemos ver el 19 de la misma
manera que vemos la influencia
estacional una amenaza para la salud un
virus que seguirá matando pero un virus
que no está interrumpiendo nuestra
sociedad o nuestro sistema hospitalarios
Y creo que eso vendrá Como dijo Pedro
este año
cambiamos de tema porque luego de que la
oposición ecuatoriana activara el
mecanismo de juicio político contra el
presidente Guillermo lasso la
confederación de nacionalidades
indígenas pidió la inmediata salida del
mandatario la oposición acusa al jefe de
estado de presunta corrupción y
malversación de fondos Mientras que el
gobierno calificó el pedido de atentado
contra la democracia y un nuevo intento
de desestabilización Por lo cual el país
exige la salida inmediata del gobierno
de Guillermo lasso y todo su equipo de
gobierno
apoyamos y exigimos al proceso de juicio
político y su destitución por sus nexos
evidentes con las mafias que azotan el
país la corrupción en las empresas de
administración pública y todo este tema
de la inseguridad en el Ecuador pasamos
a Venezuela ya que el tribunal supremo
anuló un polémico artículo del Código de
Justicia militar que penalizaba la
homosexualidad dentro de las fuerzas
armadas una falta que podía recibir una
pena de hasta tres años de prisión la
sala constitucional del máximo tribunal
señaló que la Norma establecida que
estipulaba la condena del militar que
cometiera actos sexuales contra Natura
nos resulta compatible con la
Constitución y con instrumentos
internacionales la decisión del tribunal
es considerada como una victoria por
integrantes del colectivo lgtb y más en
Venezuela
primeramente estamos muy felices de esta
Victoria que obtuvo el movimiento lgbt
en Venezuela
logramos La abolición de la
criminalización de la homosexualidad
llevamos muchísimos años luchando para
que se despenalizara y se aboliera esta
criminalización el canal de YouTube del
expresidente estadounidense Donald Trump
fue reactivado este viernes por lo que
el precandidato republicano podrá volver
a subir contenido la plataforma anunció
que tras una cuidadosa evaluación
determinaron que es parte del equilibrio
que los votantes escuchen por igual a
los principales candidatos previo a las
elecciones de 2024 en Estados Unidos la
cuenta del ex jefe de estado quedó
vetada tras el asalto al Capitolio de
y este 17 de marzo se conmemoró el día
de San Patricio patrón de Irlanda
precisamente por la gran herencia
irlandesa en Estados Unidos la
festividad se celebra a lo grande en
varias ciudades del país en Chicago el
río se volvió a pintar de verde y en
Nueva York el tradicional desfile volvió
a llenar las calles de Manhattan una
tradición que se celebra desde
1762 el alcalde de la gran manzana
destacó las raíces irlandesas de su
apellido Adams y recordó que la ciudad
fue levantada entre otros por miles de
inmigrantes irlandeses
así llegamos al final de esta emisión de
directo América aquí en France 24 a
ustedes Les agradecemos su sintonía y
los invitamos a continuar con nosotros
que ya llega Natalia Cabrera con toda la
información del continente americano en
aquí América feliz noche para todos
[Música]